here's where we begin as i said at the
beginning right on top of the sheet says
multiply the following matrices by first
working out the relevant
dot products right so that's going to be
single numbers that we get out of this
and then a range here now this is a bit
different to the one i gave you before
so i will show you how to go through
this step by step okay
so first you've got up here
right you've got a row right
here and then you've got a column
now this is important think about the
implications for this right
always you do rows first and then you
multiply by columns
right and then we're going to take the
sum of everything okay
so the first dot product right which i'm
going to write up in the corner
is going to be three times four
plus eight times one i'm matching up
right
think of the sushi again okay i've got
these two kinds of sushi and they match
up to
these two kinds of sushi across multiple
days okay
so three times four i'm even going to
write this down so i
don't screw it up and you can see
exactly what's going on
plus eight times one
okay that's going to be my first dot
product
and now i move from left to right okay
so i'm going to do this row again
but i'm going to move over to the next
column okay so this time
i'm going to make this matrix this is
why it's not going to be enough room on
your sheet of paper
okay i'm gonna make this really large so
you can see all the working
i'll match up the three this time with
the zero
right and the eight is going to go down
to the nine so
it matches up again by going downward
okay so there's the first two right that
have come from
this row and now i move down okay so to
get the row here
i'm going to look across right
all right so now i'm going to match up
again i'm gonna go four times
four plus you can tell me what's next
think carefully i'm always going to
match up i always progress
yeah so as i progress this way i
progress down so six times one
okay and now as i move from left to
right i'll move from left
to right okay you see what's going on so
i match again
four times zero six times
nine okay
so what i got let's see let's actually
compute these now uh
12 plus 8 that's going to be 20.
0 plus 72
16 plus 6
and 54.
there you go okay now you've always got
to ask the question what did i just do
what did i just calculate like what is
the significance of these
numbers with reference to where we began
well i gave you one example with the
sushi that's why i started off that way
but as you will discover you can do all
kinds of other things with
what does this symbolize depending on
the information that you begin with
okay